das ist auch wenn es nicht so aussieht
manche sagen es ist eine Vase es ist
aber in Wirklichkeit eine Lostrommel da
sich lose darin befinden das sind
harmlose das sind die Grünen Fragen und
gemeine Fragen die sind rot
gekennzeichnet du kannst wählen ja dann
nehmen
wir okay führt der Erfolg bei Frauen zum
rin für mich nicht weil Frauen ist das
Schönste was es gibt geben die nicht zu
viel Geld aus ist der Hintergrund dieser
gemeinen Frage
ähm ich habe ja kein Geld zur Verfügung
für Frauen aber du hast es mal gehabt ja
aber ich war immer ein Geber wie gesagt
ich habe dadurch natürlich viel viel
Geld verloren für Frauen ich habe viele
Nächte an Bars den Dings ausgegeben und
auch Urlaubsreisen gemacht aber was wäre
das Leben ohne diese ganzen Accessoires
ja also dafür gebe ich gerne das Geld
aus aber ruinieren seelisch haben haben
sie mich mehrfach ruiniert ja aber nicht
finanziell so nehmen wir mal wieder ein
rot mhm
was macht sie so unausstehlich dass sie
von ihren Frauen verlassen wurden also
unausstehlich war ich ja nie sondern ich
habe ich war oft sagen wir mal
gefährlich weil ich die
Frauen natürlich weil ich so unsteht war
und wechselseitig wechselhaft war und
immer unterwegs war und nie richtig Zeit
mir genommen habe haben die Frauen
gesagt dass ich suche mir über einen
anderen das heißt oft betrogen nein
nicht nicht nur das sondern einfach ja
oft betrogen ist ich habe sie nicht
betrogen sie sind ja zum Teil heute noch
meine Freundin ich habe eine andere Art
von Treue muss ich sagen im bürgerlichen
Sinne im bürgerlichen Sinne aber das
bürgerliche interessiert mich dabei
nicht
ich bin trotzdem diesen Frauen immer
treu gewesen und respektvoll begegnet
aber ich war natürlich im Sinne von
Berlusconi natürlich nicht nur nur
manchmal
Tru also die Frauen haben das
offensichtlich anders gesehen mit der
Treue ist do klar Frauen sind n mal so
gestrickt die sind ja auch anders als
und männer sind anders gestrickt ja das
ist do
klar so und dann woll mal sehen was da
so ein harmloses ist was sich dahinter
verbgt vielleicht ist das noch
schlimmer
woher haben sie ihr großes Maul ja was
TA was ist das Talent was für ein Talent
ach so sie meinen Songwriter Talent ja
das ist einfach eine Folge von
Entwicklung dass man sich mit etwas
beschäftigt und sagt ja das liegt mir so
ich bin natürlich kein Mathematiker
Naturwissenschaftler bin ich natürlich
nicht ich bin auch kein intellektueller
ich bin ein Bauchmensch und dadurch dass
ich vielleicht auch so viel Mist erlebt
habe habe ich auch das Talent diesen
diesen Mist
m zu beschreiben in Liedern ja ich ich
konnte auch als Kind oder als Schüler
immer super gute Aufsätze schreiben ich
kann gut formulieren woher kommt das ich
habe viel gelesen viel gelesen viel
gelesen viel gelesen ich habe viel
gelesen und viel Musik gehört englische
Musik wo ich dann gesagt habe moment mal
W singt der eigentlich übersetz mir das
mal gerade wenn ich französische Musik
höre also das fingt an mit George BR
Charles
asav Pierre P moment mal worüber singen
die Eros Ramazotti keine Ahnung worüber
singt bitte kla Bruni kla Bruni bitte
sag mir mal wovon du singst ja ja und da
habe ich dann immer Leute die mir das
eben übersetzt haben und daher kommt das
mein Talent es ist einfach nur habe ich
mir angeeignet vielen Dank